[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
they think it's all over for 55 years
those famous words have conjured
memories of english football's greatest
triumph
this evening the current crop of
international stars has the chance to
write
its own piece of history if they do new
memories will be made
and new phrases may be immortalized to
accompany them
we hope so because on this show we're
obviously above tired cliches
now one area where some people may think
it's almost all over but it really isn't
is the fight against kobit 19. a week
tomorrow restrictions in england are set
to be lifted
but as cases continue to rise there are
concerns about what the consequences of
that will be
the government continues to trumpet the
success of its vaccine rollout
but the pace of vaccination is slowing
and ministers are considering
reducing the gap between first and
second doses
so even that is coming under close
scrutiny
well today we'll be putting questions
about that vaccine rollout to the
perfect person
the vaccine's minister nadim zahawi
he'll be joining us
in just a moment now despite the fact
that we're above football cliches you
could describe today
as a show of two halves later we'll be
looking ahead
uh of the euro 2020 final with former
england defender martin killed
and getting the view from the italian
side with italy's top defender
their ambassador to the uk rafaela
trombetta
we'll also be speaking to the shadow
education secretary kate green
and the national statistician sir ian
diamond who sits on
sage but first
boris johnson is expected to confirm
tomorrow that lockdown restrictions will
be lifted on july the 19th
despite the rise we're seeing in
infections to talk about that and much
more we're joined by one of the
government's top strikers
the vaccine minister nadim zahawi
good morning minister now tomorrow the
prime minister says he's going to
confirm
whether july the 19th will herald
the lifting of restrictions are you
seeing anything in the data
that might prevent him giving us the
green light
so you're quite right tomorrow the prime
minister will as he
outlined a week ago that
he will share with the country the
latest data
the really good news is that 86 percent
now
almost 87 of all adults have got the
protection of
one dose and uh 65 percent
and are protected with two doses the
target is that we get to 66 percent
uh double jabbed by the 19th of july
we will meet that target so i'm
confident
that we can proceed uh to step forward
cautiously and
we will be setting out tomorrow
guidelines on everything from mask
wearing
the transition from sort of you know
mandating or or government by dictat to
uh taking personal responsibility
whether
for our own actions or corporate
responsibility at sky
and obviously at transport for london
and elsewhere
about proceeding cautiously i think you
said it at the outset
of your programme this pandemic is not
over
we're seeing a rise in infection
rates in this country but also uh in
europe and elsewhere the difference is
for us is that the vaccination program
has been so successful that we are as i
say
almost 87 of all adults have been
protected with one dose and we will hit
that 66 percent with double dose
so it was right to give ourselves a bit
more time if you remember we paused for
four weeks
to be able to protect more people
minister does does all of that program
include the prospect of reducing the
interval between first and second doses
uh as is being reported this morning
no i i i'm slightly puzzled where that
story has come from because
um obviously i engage uh almost on a
daily basis with my colleagues at the
jcvi
and professor wei shen and professor
anti handen who
um look at this very closely the real
world data
the the clinical data suggests that
actually the eight-week interval
offers that you know additional
fortification in terms of protection
with the two doses much better
than having the interval shortened any
further and of course the prime minister
announced that now
uh we've brought down that interval from
12 to eight weeks for
all adults uh so anybody who gets their
first dose
uh now and i absolutely encourage
everyone as hopefully they'll be doing
we've got a
a a site next to wembley stadium who
will be
also offering those jabs and at millwall
stadium and lots of other
football states of ittihad and elsewhere
if they get their jab
now they'll get their second jab within
that eight-week interval that is the
clinical
advice and that's the advice we will
follow so we can be clear
um you know to to take today's jargon
that
um uh when it comes to vaccine you have
to hold and you have to give at the
right time
you've decided actually that there is
going to be no change on that
well obviously the joint committee on
vaccination immunization these are the
the experts look at this all the time
and their advice is very clear that the
real world
data suggests that the eight-week
interval is
actually the best in terms of giving
everyone who's had their first dose
their second dose and that protection
the added boost in terms of both
uh antibodies and t cells is within that
eight-week interval rather than
shortening it any further
okay let's clear up one thing uh that
has created a small mystery this week
you and other ministers have been saying
for some weeks
that the link between vaccination and
serious illness hospitalization and
death has been weakened but not broken
but on wednesday the prime minister said
it has been broken now if anybody
should know what the truth of that is
it's you
what is true has the link been weakened
or has it actually been
broken well i think the prime minister
at the press conference last week
talked about as did patrick valance well
that's so so
clear he said at prime minister's
questions
that uh we scientists are absolutely
clear
that we have severed the link now is he
right
or are you still saying what you did
before
which is that it's weakened
i think there's there's you know whether
it's
the the language of sort of completely
severing the link or otherwise
um the the reality is that
we through the vaccination program have
severely weakened
the link between infection rates and
hospitalization of serous
infection if you look at the data so i
looked at this before coming on your
show
as of friday in terms of people in
hospital
62 62 of those in hospital of the 2
300 people in hospital in england 62
percent
are under the age of 55
in the previous waves that would have
been the other way around so it would
have been the majority would have been
over
the age of 55. only 15 percent
are over 75 so it is weakened but people
are still obviously
uh getting infected the majority of
people who are
severely infected are those who are
unvaccinated which is why
i go back to the same message you know
if you haven't been vaccinated get
vaccinated
i i i i get i get all of that but
we're not dancing on the head of a pin
here the distinction is important
uh whether i have broken my arm or i
have severed my arm
rather different different situations so
what we're being clear about this
morning
is that we're still in the realm of the
link
being weakened but not severed so the
prime minister
let's call it misspoke
it has been severely weakened
through the vaccination program and the
promise i think i i listened to the
press conference that
he spoke very clearly um as did patrick
valas that the link has been weakened by
the vaccination program the success of
the vaccination program
i think it's important that we remain
cautious and careful and the guidelines
that we'll set out
tomorrow will demonstrate that including
guidelines
that people are expected to wear masks
in
indoor enclosed spaces um and of course
to remain vigilant with you know hands
and and face and and
to just remember that if we all act
responsibly as we did with the
vaccination program
the nation came together to vaccinate 80
000 vaccinated volunteers
who came forward retire out of
retirement and to vaccinate
we can come together and deal with this
uh pandemic in a way that is responsible
by by thinking about our own actions and
how they impact other people
including of course people who are maybe
immunocompromised all right
minister i'm sorry if i i appear to be
hurrying you up a little bit but there's
a lot to talk about a lot to get
clear um the office for national
statistics tells us that the
seven day average for vaccinations
dropped from over 200
000 in late june to just around 100
000 at the beginning of july would you
accept that we're running into a period
of slower vaccination rates
yes i do and these are the hard yards uh
trevor so
back to the numbers i quoted earlier
we're almost at 87
of all adults have now got their first
dose the majority
we were running at about 96 return for
their second dose i want to get that
to 100 if i can the office for national
statistics
also say that 96 of all adults
will very likely take the vaccine if
they think very positively about
vaccines
so the hard yards are to get that 86 87
where we are today 290 plus percent
vaccinated because actually what we need
to make sure is
as the virus gets desperate and attempts
to
infect people to mutate and be able to
survive
it we should continue to fortify the the
nation
with the vaccination program because
that is the way we we
transition it from pandemic to endemic
uh status and deal with it in the future
with the booster campaign in september
as per the interim advice from jcvi and
of course then maybe an annual
vaccination program for covert
as well as the flu uh which we're
planning um
to begin from september and look at how
we can co-administer flu and
and covert the reason the reason i um
asked you about that
minister is that there's a crunch coming
here isn't there
um your boss health secretary says that
we might be looking at a hundred
thousand infections a day that if we
keep the
pinging regime as it is we might be
talking about
a million and more people being pinged
and self-isolating
every week and that's just if we assume
that it's just two infections per person
and
nobody's sure about that the point is
that the government has rested pretty
much everything
on your continuing success uh on keeping
the vaccine roll out at
pace the problem is
you guys are taking a bit of a punt here
aren't you you are gambling
that the vaccine rollout can keep ahead
of all of those other problems including
the possibility of variant
it is a gamble
so trevor there are no easy decisions
to make on this and let me try and bring
it to life for your viewers
on friday i do my constituency surgery
i went to visit a business in ulster
called orange mabel
which is a a lovely tea shop in in
ulster who's
really weathered the storm and survived
through the pandemic
and has reopened and is trying
everything uh
they can to continue to survive and
thrive
they lost two members of staff to
suicide
uh because of the lockdown so there are
other damage
that is being done through uh
the the severe uh lockdown that we have
endured
now the vaccination program you're right
the vaccination program is our way out
of this so
at 87 percent almost of all adults
um vaccinated with one dose two-thirds
with two doses
i think it's the right time because
obviously as we
take advantage of the summer where
schools you know being out will
have a downward pressure on the r number
of course the socializing
and interaction has an upward pressure
but there is no perfect timing for this
it's the right thing to do because
actually as the secretary of state
you mentioned that in his interview
today in the the telegraph
uh talks about 13 million uh operations
that we need to make sure
happy and the nhs is it stands ready
so there is no timing we just have to
remain cautious should come to that in a
second but just let's just
deal with the next couple of months
could you actually tilt the playing
field a bit
in in your favor by doing a couple doing
certain things for example um
at one point we talked about test and
release that is to say people like me
who've had two
old people who've had two vaccinations
could be tested rather than having to
self-isolate
or that we could release
um nhs staff from the possibility of
self-isolation
now are you thinking seriously
about those kinds of steps that would at
least
uh take away some of the potential for
chaos
yeah so really good point so the um
nhs app one has been an incredible
success
25 million downloads of the nhs app
hundreds of thousands of people
saved from hat being infected but of
course the app was developed
and operationalized at a time when we
didn't have vaccines
um now we're we're in a world where we
have almost 87
of people protected with one dose
two-thirds with two doses
about 19. so we should absolutely and
the team are looking
at how we use that app in terms of
alerting people
uh to those around them uh who test
positive of course if you do test
positive
you have to and should rightly uh uh
then self-isolate but it's important to
look at that in a
new context of this massive vaccination
program and make sure that it is fit for
purpose for this new world
including for example being able to take
maybe you know five days
as we have piloted of lateral flow tests
and upload them
to the system rather than having to
self-isolate
in the case of nhs workers if they're
wearing their protective
equipment and ppe then they'd
even today they don't need to
self-isolate
if they if they feel that they've
they've already been pinged
it's advisory but if they feel they've
protected themselves
properly then they don't need to
self-isolate hence why they're
able to uh plan for how we cope
with what the secretary of state talks
about which is getting back to to a
place where we can
have those 13 million operations happen
so those with cancer
19 out of 20 getting getting the people
they need already but we want to be at
20 out of 20.
so those tweaks are on the table that's
uh
that's that's news for us can i just
take you to the point you were
discussing a moment ago which is the
uh backlog health secretary says
possibly 13
million people how will
opening up july on july 19
help in any way in dealing with
that backlog of 13 million
patients who the health secretary
himself says have not
come forward in the last year year and a
half
i mean how does that make sense
well because as he quite rightly
outlined in his interview
that it's that sort of british sense of
of wanting to protect
the nhs and fairness and whilst we we
are in
a severe lockdown people may have not
been coming forward i think it's right
now
with the billion pounds that is totally
focused
that we have made available to the nhs
on dealing with that backlog that the
nhs now is able
to do that it has done that for cancer
patients throughout the pandemic and
i absolutely um admire
and hold in real or
my colleagues in the nhs and what
they've been able to do but this is the
time
now to effectively make sure
that we support the nhs to deal with
that whilst
also making sure we do the the booster
campaign in september
and the flu inoculation september
because
actually what you want to make sure is
in the autumn period where we haven't
had much flu virus circulating
in communities we protect against flu
and covid
because in a bad year you know 20 000
people could could uh
perish because of the flu virus so so
this is just let's get this absolutely
clear i mean it sounds like what you're
really saying here is
that you think that the possibility of a
hundred thousand infections a day
is less alarming than for example
uh the problem that you're looking
forward to
or your the prospect of uh problems
in the autumn of a different kind
flew and so forth to can you just get
clear with us what is it that has
persuaded you
to take effectively effectively to take
this risk that we might find ourselves
with this huge number
of infections with all that implies for
the
uh raised possibility of mutations and
new variants
that the vaccines can't deal with
so it's worth just reminding your
viewers
that our very strong stringent border
controls
continue and you have to take a test
before travel
a test after two days of being here the
red list
it remains in place for over 50
countries that's really important
because that's how
even if you are double uh vaccinated
and you want to come in from an
ambulance country
you still have to take that test after
two days of arrival so
we're not you know throwing caution to
the wind in this case
the guidelines you will see next week
will
also demonstrate very clearly what
people need to do
and are expected to do for example on
mask wearing
all these things are a cautious but
pragmatic way
of getting us back to as close to normal
as possible
by the 19th of july now the important
thing to remember
is that this is this is not over yet and
we have to be careful
we have to be vigilant we have to see
what's happening in other countries
vis-a-vis variants you're absolutely
right and you'll you you know that that
will continue that will not change
so this is not a you know let's just go
out and
forget about the virus the virus is
still with us and we have to be cautious
but it's the right thing to do because
as i just i hope described to you what
was a moving experience for me on friday
of a businesswoman telling me that two
of her staff committed suicide because
of lockdown
all right uh minister so much more
that we could be talking about but
unfortunately today is today
and i had to take just a few seconds to
ask you
a question that we're asking all our
guests today um
what's the score tonight going to be
i am not even going to attempt to answer
that question
because i do not want to jinx it i
traveled with england to germany
and i traveled to japan no no no no
uh you you can't see but i have a
whiteboard here
there are thousands and millions of
people
who are hanging on your every word and
we cannot leave this interview without
a number two numbers on this whiteboard
come on
i'm not gonna do it i am not gonna do it
i can't it's too painful i've
55 okay years ago we had a win
we will win tonight i am 54 years old
and i literally as i say i'm a football
fan i travel with
england to germany and to japan i am not
going to jinx it today this morning
to your viewers right but we're going to
win all right i have i have written the
word chicken
on my whiteboard here let me let me see
if you've got an answer to this question
bank holiday or not if we win
i'm not going to jinx that either there
is no way i'm going to be presumptuous
on your program
and say that we're going to have a bank
holiday okay
uh okay double chicken nando's here
thank you very much minister
great to see you okay
as we were just discussing covert case
numbers are on the rise but it's as yet
unclear whether the link between cases
and serious illness and death
has been broken or just weakened
one person who might be able to shed
some light on this is the man who
understands the data as well as anybody
the national statistician sir ian
diamond who joins
us now
um syrian you're you're the national
stato in today's lexicon and one of the
measures that you
keep an eye on is the prevalence of
antibodies whether
they come into us by vaccination or
by infection um but it's a sign of
how close we are to this thing that
people talk about herd immunity
how do you think we're doing right now
on that as i said trevor good morning
it's lovely to see you
um i have to say that i think uh with
regard to antibodies
we are uh doing very very well i'd have
to say that
uh antibodies aren't a perfect
protection
but at the same time uh we're saying
very clearly that we think
uh that about nine in ten people
uh in england in wales and in northern
ireland about eight in
ten uh in scotland uh do uh
uh have antibodies uh at the moment and
let's be fair that's up from two in ten
in um in january so i think that is an
enormous
uh increase um i have to say the the the
group
with the lowest um at around about 60
percent
is um those age uh
15 to 24. so um clearly
the vaccination program that the
minister was just talking about
remains incredibly important but
certainly we're making an enormous
amount of progress an absolutely
admirable amount of progress
okay so we're moving along though we've
got some work to do with younger people
one of the uh issues where there's
uncertainty
is about the relationship between the
average number of contacts
that an infected person has and the
likely
probability of of infection and based on
what we've seen
previously at the moment they're talking
about
two infections uh per infected person as
it were
um based on what we've seen before how
many contacts do you think
each positive case is likely to be
having uh
in the next period i
i mean i mean trevor it that's an
incredibly
well it's not just a difficult to me
it's always an impossible question
um because i don't need to talk to you
about distributions and i don't need to
talk to you about
the the the the challenge uh of looking
at i should also say
um that you know it really does
depend uh on uh the contact professor
kath notes at least university has
spoken eloquently
about different uh types of contacts and
how
you could um get a contact but you'd be
so unlucky
just from walking past someone as
opposed to uh
very close contact in a crowded space so
i just think the numbers don't talk
about the context and it would be wrong
to answer that
okay but um do you think that the
health secretary's uh estimate is not an
estimate but
his uh upper um
projection if you like of a hundred
thousand in
uh infections a day do you think that's
credible well i think what we're seeing
at the moment
uh and let me be clear we are keeping
an absolutely close uh minute-by-minute
uh on the the number of
uh infections that we are seeing in our
very very large survey which
which does give us you know some of the
best data in the world because let's
remember
uh many people uh who who do get the
virus
are asymptomatic and and those data will
continue to be incredibly important and
i thank everybody
who who takes part in them what we are
seeing
is yes uh an increase so our most recent
data uh for for england
um as uh as an about one in
160 people that's about 0.6 of a percent
now that's going up quite quickly
having said that it's still less than
slightly less than a third of where we
were on the 2nd of january
uh this year scotland is a bit higher
um although the numbers of infections
seem to be flattening
a little um in um so
look sure the numbers are going up
they're driven
largely i would have to say by at the
moment the big increases in the
northeast
the northwest had big increases and is
at the same levels of the northeast it's
a slight
trend towards a flattening there and
things are are very much lower with the
lowest levels in the east of england
than the southeast
of england so at the moment definitely
an increase driven by uh at the moment
lastly the northeast and driven very
much
uh by people uh aged uh 18 to
24 we're seeing very very little
uh increase um in people
uh age over 50 for example
and i think that's that that's
encouraging so i'm
i'm not going to do murder with um
projections into the future but i'd have
to say
the projections into the future uh have
very large confidence intervals
uh associated with them but you don't
rule out the possibility of a hundred
thousand a day
well i don't think i think it would be
wrong to to completely
rule it out but i would have to say that
at the moment we don't have the data
either
uh really to to put a a firm number
on things but we are seeing a a steady
uh and fast increase in the northeast
steady increases
uh elsewhere as i say low increases in
the southeast and the east of england
underlying the judgments that the
government has to make
which are not your judgment i understand
that you're not in this field but
underlying it is um a view about whether
the link between infection and
hospitalization
and serious disease and death has
truly been broken now you know
in the stats word we'd be talking about
random relationships and all of that but
you know in simple terms where do you
stand on this do you think
that link has effectively been broken or
not
but i'm i i'm in the severely weakened
uh
for the very simple reason that we need
to continue
tirelessly to look at the data uh and we
are at
the if you like uh the the beginning uh
at the moment
um of of looking at this and all the
evidence as the
taxi minister just said to you uh is
that
that we have a younger uh cohort of
people being hospitalized at the moment
and while hospitalizations are going up
uh they
are now uh a long way fro from some of
the levels
we have seen uh before um and
so i'm very hopeful um that we have
really made a strong um
break uh but at the same time um
i would have to say at the moment all
the evidence allows me to say severely
weakened
taking all of this to together and i
want to ask you about a particular
event as a sort of example of
judgment that has to be made um next
month
manchester united play leads first game
of the season 14th of august 75 000
people
at old trafford now um
were you to be offered uh a ticket for
that
game would you be going along
to spend the afternoon 75 000 people
most of whom would not be wearing masks
uh given the levels of compliance
what would you what would you advise
well trevor i spent a long time first of
all if it was you who
was offering me the ticket try to swap
it for one at talker united
having said that um a couple of points
you made you know
why is it that uh you say
that not many people would be wearing
masks we are
seeing from our our our data
our our opinions and lifestyle survey
that um
the great majority of people are saying
they would
continue to wear masks in crowded places
where i'd be going i would be wearing a
mask so
i mean i think i think you know we have
to think very carefully
um about we're making
those uh kind uh of assumptions
um and you know and i do think
um that again people will be making
decisions
uh on the basis of what they see uh the
risk
at that time uh and i'm sure the great
majority of people
would be looking at um both both
that risk and what the risks were before
taking
the final decision okay so
you're probably the most statistically
literate
guest that we've ever had on this
program
statistically speaking what's gonna
happen tonight
oh well look i've been saying uh to
anyone who will ask one one after extra
time and we will win on penalties
penalties okay
okay coming home trevor
[Laughter]
you've actually anticipated my question
thank you so england win on penalties
no question you heard it here first
sarian thank you very much indeed thank
you
now labor has suggested it does support
the lifting restrictions on july the
19th but sakia starman will
still warn this week that the
government's approach could lead to a
summer of chaos and confusion
let's find out where labour really
stands on everything we've been
discussing so far we're joined by
one of zakir's holding midfielders the
party's shadow education secretary
kate green kate green
would you support the reduction of an
interval between
the first and second jabs if the jcvi
were to recommend it
i know we heard from nadim zahavi he's
not thinking about it but
it's obviously in the air clearly if
there is
advice from the jcvi that that would be
a safe and sensible measure we've always
said
that it's right to act on the advice and
clearly the vaccination program has been
a hugely important tool in our ability
to combat the virus but the priority of
course now is also to make sure that
people who have not been vaccinated
at all and get the vaccine and
it is concerning that the rate of
vaccinations is slowing and that some
groups have still not
been able to come forward and be
vaccinated and so i think the priority
has got to be to spread the vaccine
program to the maximum so that we keep
everyone as safe as possible
this is interesting because um you
you're now telling me that you're
worried about the pace of vaccination
which we
see slowing down as i discussed with the
minister
secure described the government's course
as
reckless yet as far as we understand it
labor is supporting the government's
decision
to lift restrictions on july the 19th
isn't that a bit like
saying that the driver's gone
a bit bonkers but we are completely
content to let him
drive us into the ditch well we do want
to see the restrictions lifted on the
19th subject to
the data and i think we're still waiting
for that final data um
in the coming day or two um but what we
don't want
is to lift those the restrictions
without keeping mitigations in place
that would enable that to happen more
safely so for example that's
why we've said that the mandatory mass
squaring should continue in public
places that's why we've said
that there should be more support and
requirement on public spaces
to have proper ventilation systems
that's why we've said
that the financial support for people on
low incomes who have to isolate needs to
be adequate so that they can afford to
do that
so yes we do want to see the
restrictions lifted if the data
confirmed that that's
the right thing to do and i i hope
another indication seemed to be that it
that it will do um but we want that
with the the mitigations kept in place
okay well
let's test this this out a little bit
and take a concrete example
um you just raise the question of mask
discipline
now what the government's going to do is
allow people to
go to nightclubs abandon social
distancing
and the rule of thirty no requirement
for nightclubs now
it may be that you and i won't be
particularly vulnerable
to that i don't know you know how how we
might spend our fridays and saturday
nights uh next month
but is it your idea that as long as we
keep marks on
it doesn't matter how up close and
personal we get in nightclubs
well first of all trevor i'm not one of
the world's great clubbers i wish you'd
asked me the old trafford question since
i'm sitting just i'm coming to
wait don't worry we will get there good
excellent
but you know it's masks are not the only
protection and
venues will be looking at putting in
place a whole range of mitigations and
it's absolutely
right that they should and that they
should be subject to the proper health
and safety requirements that are placed
on them
but you know masks we've just heard from
syrian diamonds people want to wear
masks most people feel more comfortable
and confident
when others are wearing masks around
them and i think this oh we'll leave it
up to individuals people can take
personal responsibility
that's a recipe for confusion i'm afraid
it's probably
a recipe for more confrontations um and
i just think it would be much clearer
and simpler for the government to keep
mandatory mass wearing in public places
uh in place after the 19th of july but
what
why don't you guys follow through then
and say
look you know what the nightclubs we're
not
ready for that why don't you just have
the courage of your convictions
and say that i think it is very
important that we get the balance
between
health and people's economic well-being
which after all is an important factor
in good health
get that balance right and of course we
know that the uh hospitality and
entertainment sector has suffered
terribly in this pandemic
i am concerned that we should respond
very quickly to
any new data we receive and uh that's
um that all the protections that we can
put in place
are put in place and i'm going back to
your first point trevor
it is really important especially if the
typical clubber is probably younger
that we make sure that that vaccination
program reaches
everybody who should be receiving a
vaccine and particularly young people
so that we make everyone as safe as
possible okay let me just
try one last test of your position and
this is something you can't
uh get put on the government um
the two mayors of the largest
uh cities or first and third largest
cities
uh sadiq khan and andy burnham
have the tube and the tram under their
control
will they be requiring a mandatory
mask on those uh forms of transport
it's in their hands what is labour going
to say about that
i hope they will and i believe i'm i
think i'm right in saying that andy has
already
indicated that here in manchester that's
what he will do
um i certainly think that um having
traveled regularly on both the tube and
the tram
and all through the um pandemic when i
was allowed to
that wearing masks and seeing other
others wearing masses a source of great
reassurance and people want to do it
okay uh the old trafford question
manchester united playing leads 14th of
august
um are you fine with 74 000 people
turning up
most of them without masks well as
syrian said i don't think we know that
it's most of them without masks and i do
know having a long-standing relationship
with manchester united they're in my
constituency here
um that they will go to great lengths to
to keep people safe and
make sure that protections and
mitigations are in place
are you you're going to be there right
no i'm not sadly i'm this ticket you're
offering if it's still going spare you
know send it my way but um
i would really encourage people who are
going to that game to keep themselves
and others around themselves and please
wear a mask and follow the instructions
that stewards are giving you
um because you know it's it's outdoors
there's less risk of infection spreading
when you are outdoors as
as we know but i think every measure
that we can take we should take
to defeat this terrible virus okay
you you've issued a statement today
about the government's plans for
legislation against hate speech
in higher education and
um what you said or what the party has
said in its
release is labour say the law is trying
to solve the problem
doesn't exist uh let me read you some
names
jk rowling julie bindl amber rudd
selena todd kevin price
uh you know what they've all got in
common they have all been
cancelled in fact one's lost their job
over the what they have said
about the issue of women as a sex
uh as opposed to um the the view that's
taken by some
trans rights activists that uh there is
no such thing essentially
now are you really saying that there is
nothing to see here
this problem doesn't exist there are
and always have been a small a very
small
number of instances and i
think those examples that you gave um
in many cases perhaps in all cases i'm
not familiar with every single one of
those examples trevor
it was going to give you another dozen
well please but
trevor last in the last year for which
we have data out of 10 000 events only
six were cancelled
four because they had their own
paperwork one went to another venue one
was a pyramid scheme
if you look across the piece there are a
very small number of events that are
cancelled i think there is
obviously a concern about the atmosphere
the climate on campus
but that cuts both ways and if we have
as i believe this legislation does
um a law that allows people actually to
come on campus
as holocaust deniers to spread hate
speech anti-faxers
i don't think that's in the public
interest and i think that has a chilling
effect and i think
we don't need this legislation we
already have faithful
on campus in law and i think that this
actually
gives sucker to people who want to sow
hate and division and to their lawyers
they'll be running off
particularly on the basis of a small
number of cases
if i may say so you say it's a small
number of cases but for every individual
who is fired because of what they have
said it's a hundred percent
so let me just ask you again is the
labor view
it that nothing to see here
i'm not saying there are no cases at all
what i am saying is
it's a very small number of incidents
when you look at the number of events
that have gone ahead
quite satisfactorily on campus and that
we already have
satisfactory legislation we've had it
going back to the 1986 education
act and then strengthened i would say by
labour's human rights act
what we don't need is legislation that
now allows holocaust deniers
anti-vaxxers people spreading hate
speech
to run off to the courts if a student
union or university says
okay all right um i don't want that and
i don't think
okay okay kate green i know you know a
lot about education but i think you know
quite a lot about football as well
what's a score tonight
what is going on here uh that
are we now a country of snowflakes who
can't even predict our own victory
i will make it i will make oh no you're
back
okay apparently um viewers the line
has frozen oh i'm i'm being told
kate is the best come on kate quickly
i'm going to give you a score trevor in
two one
two two one thank you kate green
our our first guest who's got the
courage to call it thank you so much
thank you now before we move on a quick
announcement
this week we were delighted that trevor
phillips on sunday received
albert's certification this is an award
given by bafta that goes to tv shows and
productions
that meet sustainable targets tackle the
environmental impact of broadcasting
and encourage others to act in a more
eco-friendly way
we do this by amongst other things
reducing and offsetting travel
minimizing our use of
energy recycling and avoiding single-use
plastic
it's all part of sky's ambition to
become net zero carbon by
2030 so you'll now see this logo at the
end of our show each week
and hopefully on other parts of sky news
very soon
now it probably hasn't escaped your
attention if i haven't done
enough to draw your attention to it but
england's footballers
are playing in their first major
tournament final in 55 years tonight
like 1966 the game will take place at
wembley and they'll be looking to win
the european championship
for the first time when they take on
italy to talk about this we're joined by
a man who won
43 england caps former arsenal defender
and invincible martin keown
martin keown um you are one of the few
living englishmen who has actually
beaten
italy in a for international and you did
that in 1997
playing alongside gareth southgate so
tonight's game's got
martin keown written all over it um
let's start with england
how do you rate this team
so england oh well you know it's a joy
to watch england play at the moment and
i
i just feel that the unity between the
people
and the players now is just an amazing
and today
for anyone lucky enough to to be in the
stadium i think it's a privilege
to be there both for the players who've
been magnificent of course the manager
has led the way
he's a very calm man they're going to
need some of that calmness today
and they've been many of us and the fans
have responded so the atmosphere today i
can only imagine
what that's going to be like the players
need to draw off it we'll all be sad we
sat at home
watching um and wishing these players
all the very best of luck
in what is an enormous game for them
they've got to try and treat it
by just any other game if they can if
possible i mean every channel they put
on there in their rooms right now
is difficult but there's a great
opportunity they've got to embrace it
love it that's the thing
love it um they seem really well
prepared
and there's a belief now that england
can be successful again
you you you might be given forgiven for
thinking looking at the coverage that
there isn't another team on
on the pitch actually but there is um so
what would you be worried about
uh on the italian side who who are the
danger men
well uh insignia on the left-hand side
is a player that
pops into little pockets and mobile a
plays really high he's going to
test our central defenders but it's
really this ferocity of their press
in their midfield they've got really
strong midfield barela
georginio plays really deep in their
midfield and he passes the ball for fun
he almost like
orchestrates things and when they get
out of rhythm in their passing it's back
to him and he resets it so
he's both very good in possession and as
a team
they're extremely well organized but but
so are we and there's a lot of talk
about the experience they have their two
central defenders
kealini you know he's 36 years of age
now
but i'd like to talk about our central
defenders i thought they'd been immense
no one's really talking too much about
them stones maguire
and walker at right back he's he's like
speedy gonzales the way he
races back and rescues everybody in
defense so
we are growing really nicely two good
midfield players
phillips rice these guys are cutting
their teeth at the really highest level
and being quite outstanding but there's
it's a 50 50 game
you know it's how you play on the day
but i feel that we've got the edge with
our front players the quality sterling
has been immense
during this competition from a technical
point of view actually what you just
said about
uh kyle walker uh john stones and harry
maguire would
suggest that you're tempted to stay uh
four three before at the back but there
is a school of thought that says
actually what we do need to do
is change formation with sake and the
team what would you
what would you say well i i would say
that we have a manager now that
wants his team to be given the best
opportunity and foot was about a numbers
game
and we've had the correct numbers in
every game that we've played and even
the last match when greed issue came on
to change the match for us was taken
back off again
demonstrated that the manager understood
what denmark were going to do
immediately there they got
behind so everything is covered but i
think both teams play four feet three
they know the strengths and it's about
who can come off the best i don't
believe we should be changing to a five
but we have the flexibility to do that
the players are all intelligent enough
to do so
you know the way that they can flip-flop
between one system and another
just shows you the change of education
um
and you know i went help with many
tournaments uh and sat with garrett
okay afterwards you know sort of
analyzing and
where do we go wrong and he's done that
brilliantly
in terms of how they go from one step to
the next and i expect them to be
really well prepared and they would have
they're envisaging every step before it
happens that's what they have to do
tactically but the players then carry
out that plan beautifully
it's just having that that strength that
because it's tough
uh sometimes to play at wembley that's
disappeared that's what's
encouraged me the most that's a joy
again now to play at wembley and after
covid and all the issues we've had and
the fans coming back
it feels so united must be an absolute
pleasure for those players to step onto
the pitch now
at wendy okay um i'd love to talk to you
about
the nature of the team and the way that
they've come to the academy in toronto
we haven't got that much time
you're the only guest who actually has
any credible
um experience to say anything about the
score
so um i'm going to ask you first of all
who wins you said it's 50 50. but if you
if you had to
put money on it well i think 2-1 i've
gone with a 2-1 and i'd like to think we
can do that
um within extra time i don't think it
will go to penalties
um i'm very confident that england can
come win this game and i'm actually you
know we we wanted to talk a little bit
this morning about how these players are
inspiring the next generation
and and i think really a lot of credit
must go to the fa with
grassroots football programs along with
mcdonald's that they've put together
and actually they're out there now in
big numbers thousands of sessions three
sessions
to introduce new young boys and girls
into football between the ages of 5-11
so
today is it's the players on the picture
will spa inspire the next generation but
it's it's that initiative from
mcdonald's in the fa to give
opportunities for the next generation to
play football which is what's going to
make us champions for the next
generation do you want to keep winning
if we can win today we don't want to be
waiting another 55 years
for more success trevor champions for
the next generation that could be the
most important thing
that comes out of today thank you so
much martin cleon
thanks joe have a good day
so that's the view from the england side
but of course italy
will be equally determined to win their
second european title this evening
roberto mancini's team have gone an
incredible 33
game unbeaten while 33 games unbeaten
quite the turnaround after failing to
qualify for the last world cup in 2018.
we're joined now by italy's official
representative in the uk
top defender one might say ambassador
raffaele trombetto
ambassador um where will you be watching
the game from tonight
a good morning festival i'll be at the
stadium i'll go stadium with the
president of the italian republic who is
coming this afternoon
and um i will be there with him and the
italian delegation
i am so envious of you but before we
talk about the game itself
what's a mood like um back home in italy
of course there is a a lot of interest a
lot of expectation
uh celebration looking forward to this
to this
this much excitement all the sort of
things that also
people in england have been experiencing
in the last in the last few few days and
and a few few weeks but at the end of
the day
it's a football match we want to enjoy
it we want to celebrate it
with our english friends both in uh in
england and
uh and in italy well uh where do you say
it's it's it's a football match you're
implying
uh contrary to what the liverpool
manager uh but frankly one
once said uh you know it's
it's it's not life and death it's more
important than that about football
um is it as important to italy to win
tonight
as it seems to be to us
well it's always important to win an
important match to win
a competition we have some experience
there
i mean we in our h3 won four world cup
we won the european cup in 1960
68 but each time it's it
it's a new experience and of course it's
it's it's important it will
it does boost the morale of our people
and
we know how important it is now for all
over the world i mean for english people
for italian people
you know to have to have some very
positive things to
to look forward and to celebrate um
english football fans know roberto
mancini pretty well from his time at
man city um do you think
that there is anything in the theory
that
uh his time in the premier league uh
has helped him to become the kind of
leader
that has engineered this extraordinary
comeback
from 2018 to now where italy
frankly looked like a pretty rolled
royce side
i don't know but i suppose when you know
you have experience
all over the world in in other
other challenges of course that make
make you
you know grow make you feel uh better
about yourself
more confident so from this point of
view i i do think that the experience
that manchini had in england
uh have helped them uh i also
has been playing uh for many years in uh
um in italy uh but as i say you know you
you
you take all the best from the different
experiences you've had in your in your
career so
i have no doubt that also the the time
that you spend in england
from this point of view has been as a
positive effect you know of his
experience as
a as a manager of italy um there's a lot
of talk here about the way that the team
has
represented uh england and has in a way
brought
the nation together united nations um in
italy of course
there is you know an historic not
division but
uh essentially there's not there's a
north and south issue that's always been
talked about in italy do the absolutely
bring
bridge that gap do you think i mean is
the italian team
bringing italy together in the way that
we talk about the english team bringing
uh england together well first of
all i would i wouldn't really describe
this as a division between the north and
south
of italy of course there are different
issues uh
in the north and and the south about the
country has been has been united
uh for for for many many many years but
definitely
uh the uh the national team is
is the team of the all of italy there is
no no really
whatsoever division even if during the
as it is here you know when the
when you play the the the the the the
national uh championship
the premier league or the the serie as
we call it of course you know you have
teams of different cities of this part
of italy and this sort of rivalry
but definitely the national team is the
moment when the
all of italy feel uh united than phil
no backing you know our team all right
um ambassador look i i couldn't have you
here
and not deal with an extremely important
question which appears to divide
our nations um i don't think you can see
it
but uh we saw a
banner uh being held up by some italian
fans
which say which says stop
putting pineapple on pizza
well look um pizza is of course the food
of heaven even the plain margarita
is a superior kind of food but it turns
out
you know it's summertime's got some
funny views about this
what is wrong with this humble fruit
that i am holding up a pineapple
why shouldn't it be a part of a pizza
of course you can choose uh whatever you
want to put on the pizza and there is
nothing wrong with the pineapple
as such but then uh you know
when you cook and when you prepare
something you always
look for the best or the best
combination of ingredients
and we we we since you know pizza is an
italian
is an italian dish he's an italian
creation we know how to do it
and we don't think that with pineapple
you would taste the pizza
at his best then of course it's also a
question of personal choice
okay i i know you've got to go though
actually the program is
going to send you a hawaiian pizza
just so you can see what it's really
like what is the score of tonight
well um my the score for me will be
2-1 to italy also because it's the same
score uh that was uh
at the previous important match both
the 1990 european camp and 2014
sorry the 99 world cup and 2014 world
cup tweet
one to italy so i want to continue let's
say
on this trend ambassador
thank you very much and uh we wish you
the best of luck
tonight uh and of course your team
though not that much luck
thank you very much indeed
so that's it for today five football
predictions well actually only three
but there's still one more i need to get
our deputy politica editor
sam coats will be joining us after the
break for
uh trevor phillips the take to go over
everything we heard
in extra time and though you may not
have much football analysis to add
i'll be asking him for a score
prediction that's straight after this
break
you